what we will talk about in this video is
the product rule which is one of the one
of the fundamental ways of evaluating
derivatives and we won't prove it in
this video but we will learn how to
apply it and all it tells us is if we
have a function that can be expressed as
the product of two functions so let's
say it can be expressed as f of X times
G of X and we want to take the
derivative of this function we want to
take the derivative of it that it's
going to be equal to the derivative of
one of these functions F prime of X
let's say the derivative of the first
one times the second function times the
second function plus plus the first
function not taking its derivative times
the derivative of the second function so
here we have two terms in each term we
took the derivative of one of the
functions and not the other and we
multiplied the derivative of the first
function times the second function plus
just the first function times the
derivative of the second function now
let's see if we can actually apply this
to actually find the derivative of
something so let's say we are dealing
with I don't know let's say we're
dealing with x squared times x squared
times cosine of X or let's say we a
short is 2x squared times sine of X if
you're done it either way and we are
curious about taking the derivative of
this we are curious about what its
derivative is well we might immediately
recognize that this is the product of
this can be expressed as a product of
two functions we could set f of X we
could set f of X is equal to x squared
so that is f of X right over there and
we could set G of X we could set G of X
to be equal to sine of X and there we
have it we have our f of X times G of X
and we could think about what these
individual derivatives are the
derivative of f of X is just going to be
equal to 2x by the power rule and the
derivative of G of X is just the
derivative of sine of X and we covered
this when we just talked about common
derivatives derivative of sine of X is
cosine of X and so now we're ready to
apply the product rule this is going to
be equal to f prime of x times G of X
so f prime of X the derivative of F is
2x times G of X which is sine of X sine
of X plus just our function f which is x
squared x squared times the derivative
of G times cosine of X times cosine of X
and we're done we just applied the
product rule